[Music]
hi I'm Jacob Ai and these are some of my
favorite things in
life oh okay yes favorite things about
Australia where I'm from which is
Brisbane Brisbane Queensland Australia I
was born and raised there there's
something about the houses like the
style of a house it's called a
queenslander and it has like an airway
underneath it and and you live upstairs
there's like an inherent Nostalgia I
guess attached to it and it's not like
anywhere I've ever been in the world
before so sometimes if I need
inspiration or something sometimes going
home to where I grew up is helpful for
that you know it's probably because I
was raised there probably has something
to do with that it's kind of this
unspoken thing when you're from there it
has like a spirit that you can't really
um articulate or put into pictures or
sounds or words it's just a feeling and
I'm sure everyone has that you know with
the place that they were born and grew
up in there's like a a Lust For
childhood or something like you're
always trying to get those days back the
next one is
music I have this like thing about
things that are under overrated
underrated the Ziggy Stardust album by
David Bowie is overrated underrated in
my opinion and just recently I been
listening to that album kind of in
everything I do particularly this song
called 5 years I love the way it sounds
and I love the way it feels and then I
kind of get more into David Bowie and I
just you can kind of because he's such a
trend Setter and like a world a world
Shaker and he had so much to say he can
he can become this like great big thing
you know and you don't really look at
the Nuance of him but I mean that guy is
a genius the next which is a constant
through sort
of my whole life and it started with the
song Perth is bonver and you can kind of
read that there's like discussions
around his music and comment threads and
it's almost like the sounds he makes
create this feeling that you can't
articulate or Express but everybody
knows that feeling somewhere somewhere
in their in their gut or in the fiber or
their being everyone on the planet I
really do think so whether it's like a
whale or a screech or the the depth that
he takes his voice or an electronic
sound it's packed with so much meaning
and that is always always inspiring to
me in the same vein is Fred again it's
the same kind of thing with the sounds
the Snippets of voices and passages that
he chooses the words are Ultra simple
but they means so much how to say as
much as you can in the simplest most
accessible way and that's something
that's always interesting to me and then
the national is also in that same world
of feeling and simplicity Simplicity of
expression you know this like you know
we're all here thing and we're all
having a go at it and all kind of doing
the best and the worst that we can and
then on top of that there's a movie come
on come on the Mike Mills film that they
all kind of link up you know in a way
and that sounds super obnoxious with my
legs crossed in a tural neck but yeah
music
Animals I mean some of this stuff is so
self-explanatory I really love animals
my dog is my best friend in the whole
world I love that dog my dog will smile
at me when she is happy and frown when I
leave and that kind of
relationship with something that kind of
looks like a Disney character is pretty
pretty fantastic I quite like seals yeah
my dog looks like a seal when she swims
they do make me laugh do you have a
particular favorite animal that is
native to Australia yeah um pretty
called oh the thorny devil it's a small
lizard and it's covered in Thorns like
uh spikes thorny devil I like
those I got together some poems that I
really like the first poem is by Philip
Lin it's called home is so sad I think
it's like it's probably because of that
like Simplicity and feeling in the
mundane kind of thing before like the
music I think it's going to be different
to every every person that reads it I
think it encourages like reflection and
any kind of retrospect on or childhood
lost or you know not lost but sort of
spent rather the last Hells is by Les
maray that's another poem that I really
like it's Ultra Australian and Les Mari
has a way of capturing I think like this
kind of blue color experience which is
somewhat similar to my own and this one
is about a father dying he's responding
to his family members and children
saying to him like don't die yet and
he's like no no I'm too busy dying to
die this this line on the second day
you're busting to talk but I'm too busy
dying grief ended when he died the Widow
like soldiers who won't live life their
mats missed I really like that and I'm
not too sure why so don't don't ask oh
uh this poem is by Arthur rimbo and it's
called Dance of the hanged men and it's
just kind of a really fun devilish kind
of poem and I really only like it
because there's a line that says the
devil's paladins the skeletons of
Saladin that kind of reminds me of the
introduction to Aladdin you know that
song that plays when the merchant is
moving through the skeletons of Saladin
it's kind of you know there's like a
trance to it the paladins of dancing
dancing the lean the devil's paladins
the skeletons of Saladin like that
sounds really cool when you say it out
loud yeah so I like
those thank you very much for listening
to me talk about things that I like I do
appreciate
it